(applause)
- Kelly, thank you for having me!
- [Kelly] Oh, absolutely.
I'm such a fan of you.
We're gonna get to it.
I'm supposed to wait 'til the second half.
But I'm very excited about
talking about Griselda.
I'm gonna hold off.
- Okay.
- 'Cause I'm gonna ask, 'cause you just
went to London, right?
I love London.
- I just went to London
and Madrid.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- And now New York and tomorrow
I go to Bogota, Colombia
and then I go to Miami.
- Oh, God.
- I know.
- No.
- Yeah.
- I quit touring.
I was like, no.
- Too bad I can't; no, I'm excited.
So I'm grateful that I get to do this
with this TV show that I really love doing
and that I'm so proud of,
but I'm exhausted, I'm
51, it's not the same.
- At 41 it's not the same.
So Formula 1 race, you
were there in Vegas -
- Yes.
- with your son, right?
Are y'all into racing?
- Well my son is obsessed.
You know, I get the
opportunity to be invited
to things like that, and of course.
He usually doesn't really
care, all the stuff that I do,
but when we heard that, he
was like, okay, we're going.
- Aw, I love it.
- It's like, you were saying
yes to that, and we did.
And it was, you know,
Vegas, right there by LA,
so it was very easy but super exciting.
- Yeah, the energy, yeah.
- You know, the energy, the men.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(laughs)
Go you.
- It's a lot going on
that weekend in Vegas.
So it's really fun, you should go.
- Oh, I've been to Vegas quite
a bit recently I feel like.
- Not to Vegas,
to the Formula 1.
- To the Formula 1.
I don't know that I've been to Formula 1
and I think I've only been to NASCAR.
If I have been to Formula 1, I'm so sorry,
I'm just not remembering right now.
But the racing in general is insane to me.
Have you ever gone really
fast in one of the cars?
Have you done it with,
like, a driver before?
I did at NASCAR with Jimmie Johnson,
it went really fast, and
I was like, I'm good.
- Why, for what?
- I don't know, I'm not,
like, a thrill seeker.
Like, I did it because they asked me to
and I was working with the company
that they were like, it'd
be cool if could do this.
I was like, all right, I'm usually game.
And then I was like, this is not me.
Yeah.
- You ever did it again?
No?
- [Kelly] No!
- Okay.
- I'm just like, why?
Why am I trying to be,
like, all rebellious?
Like, nah.
- Or sexy and cool, for what?
- I'm never aim for sexy.
(laughter)
I never, that's not my cross to bear.
- Even if you pay me to
get in a car like that,
I wouldn't do it now.
- Yeah, no, no it sounds like -
but you're saying, this is -
- Well, if you pay me enough, maybe.
(laughter)
It depends.
True for me too.
So no, but I love this about your son.
'Cause this is my dream that
one of my children will cook.
'Cause I don't like cooking.
And your son cooks really well as a chef.
- It's amazing.
He's so good at it.
You know, he saved us during the pandemic
because if not, we would have starved.
He decided, he took over,
and he would give us lunch
and dinner every day.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- We were four people
during the pandemic together in the house.
And I think he learned
even more than what he knew
because he even started doing,
like, sushi, Lebanese food.
And I'm like, what?
He taught himself how to do it.
It's amazing, yeah.
- What's, like, your proudest moment?
'Cause, as a single mom, and you play,
we're gonna get to the
movie, or the series.
But you play, she's a single mom.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] And you've been a single mom.
- So what's your proudest moment?
'Cause it's hard to be
there for everything,
to hold down a job.
- It's super hard.
And, you know, when you're
young, I was very young,
and for example, now that I'm 51,
I think we talked about it a little bit
when we were, the last
time that I saw you.
- Yeah.
- It's like, you know, we
should have done things
a little bit, you know, different,
because I didn't know, I was young,
I was 20 years old when I had Manolo,
so I was kind of raising
myself at the same time.
So what, I mean -
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I should have been going to therapy
or somebody should have been guiding me.
But I am so proud that
he turned out amazing
and super hard-working.
- Yeah.
- And that he, you know, that
he wants to do things in life
and he's excited about life.
I think that's what all
mothers, you know, wish for.
- Yeah, yeah.
And just polite and respectful.
- [Sofia] Yes, very.
- That's my thing, I'm like, if anything,
you can be any of the things,
but just kind would be good.
- Kind, yeah, be kind to other people.
I mean, I don't have anything
bad to say about my son.
So I did a great job.
- Ha, I love it!
You gotta be proud of that.
So wait, I want to show
a couple old photos
of y'all together.
So first is this.
- [Sofia] Oh!
- [Kelly] Look at you!
- [Sofia] Oh, my God, I
think that was in Miami.
Some Halloween or something.
- [Kelly] Well that's a full circle.
You're talking about a character in Miami.
- In Miami, yeah.
I remember, I think that
was around the time,
like I was dropping him to school
and he turned around and said to me,
Mom, don't forget that tomorrow,
it's like, the parents, teacher thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I'm like, yeah, sure, I know.
And then he was gonna close the door
and he turned around and said,
don't forget to dress like a mom.
(gasps)
I was like, I don't even, I'm like, wait!
Don't just say that
and get out of the car!
What does that even mean?
- My son says things to
me about my wardrobe.
He literally made me change
for my girl's night out,
just going out to dinner.
He was like, oh, so
you're gonna wear that?
And I was like, damn!
- Then you're worse than me!
Because at least I was in my 20s.
I was like 23 when he told me that!
(laughter)
- You're like, I should
be killing it right now.
No wait, they're honest kids.
I love it.
There's also this one, though,
in his favorite 101 Dalmatians
speedo, which is so great. `
(Sofia laughs)
- [Sofia] So cute.
- Where are y'all?
- That's Colombia.
I was at the beach,
that's my cousin, Joji,
and we're just at the, you know,
the local beach in Colombia.
- Yeah!
- And I had Manolo there.
- I love it!
- Oh, I haven't seen
that picture in decades.
- It's so crazy to see them
when they're small, yeah.
- I know, now he's big.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(applause)
That was a look at her new
Netflix series, Griselda,
which she stars in
and executive produces.
Congratulations on
that, that's incredible.
- That scene is very relaxing.
- Oh, I've seen other, yeah.
(Sofia laughs)
Yeah, that's more chill.
That's like, the calm before the storm.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's incredible.
I want to get into a couple parts.
But before we do, like, kind of explain
the series to everybody.
- [Sofia] Yes.
Well, it's a very interesting character
because it was a real woman that existed.
- Yeah.
- In the 70s and in the 80s in Colombia.
She became one of the
biggest drug lords in,
you know, in this business.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, you know, it's not like now,
now women can do things like
that, be to the level of men,
but in that era it was really rare.
- [Kelly] Unheard of.
- [Sofia] Yes, it was unheard.
And there has been, in history,
women that have been able
to do a little bit of that business,
but not to the level that she got to.
And she got away with it for so long
because nobody was suspecting
that it was a woman.
- Yeah.
- So there, it was like,
I mean, paralyzing to me
because, to understand that
this woman really existed
while she was raising four kids.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like, why didn't
I ever heard of her?
I live in Colombia in that
era, the 70s, the 80s, the 90s.
My brother was, unfortunately,
part of that business.
He got killed in Colombia.
And I know that character so well,
how did none of us knew about
her, about her existence?
And I started digging in, digging in,
and there's a lot on her.
- Yeah.
- There's public records,
she was in jail for 22 years,
I mean, it was a whole disaster.
- Wow, I think that's,
isn't that kind of, they say
a true boss is the one that
you don't even know exists?
- Yeah.
- Like, you know
what I'm saying?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like a true boss is one
that doesn't even have to,
like, say it?
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- It was a very difficult
story for me to understand
because it's a woman.
- Yeah, I'm like, how do you connect
with that character,
too, that's a drug lord?
- Yes, you know, I feel
like women always are,
we're protecting, like,
you know, surviving.
But I did understand her
because I was a woman,
I was Colombian, I was a
single mother like her.
I mean, she escaped
abuse when she was young.
I haven't, but, I mean, there
was a lot of similarities
and I've raised a kid on my own,
I'm an immigrant, she was an immigrant.
So there were a lot of similarities.
The thing is that she went, I want to say,
like she lost her mind and
did things in that business
that were, like, ruthless.
- Yeah.
- And she ended, not in a good way.
- Yeah, I love that tease, I love it.
So I, this is incredible.
(stammers)
I feel like
they only changed your nose or something.
- What?!
- I don't know what they did.
(laughter)
- Are you crazy?
- No I'm saying, like,
whatever they did, though,
it looked slight.
It doesn't look like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like when you look at you -
- No Kelly, it was hours.
- Here's what I'm saying.
(laughter)
No, here's what I'm saying.
It probably took time -
- Don't be jealous!
- The slight change
completely changed your being.
- It was a wig!
Shut up.
- Shut up?
(laughter)
- It was a wig!
It was a lot!
They did a lot to me.
It was teeth, it was wig, it was nose.
- [Kelly] No, but what
I'm saying, though -
- [Sofia] Plastic from here to here!
- [Kelly] But what I'm
saying is, it looks like,
no, how I'm saying is
they did such a good job
that it looked seamless
and you just looked like a different,
like you literally look
like you could actually
just be this person in other movies.
You could have two careers.
- [Sofia] See?
Like, she looks real, right?
- [Kelly] Yes!
- [Sofia] I know.
- You look like you're
a different actress,
like you could have a
whole different life.
- That's exactly what I
wanted, that reaction.
And I love that you thought
that it was just a little thing.
- [Kelly] Because they did a good job!
- Because that means it's natural.
- [Kelly] Exactly, that's what I'm saying.
I love, too, that we just
get to see you in that role.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
This is such a departure
from Modern Family,
such a departure from things.
You know, even on America's Got Talent,
your personality in general, like,
it's such a cool departure
and such a cool flex for you.
Like a cool muscle to be
able to flex for everybody.
- Well, you know, I was always worried
when I decided to do it,
I'm like, I just don't want to think,
I wanted Sofia and Gloria
Pritchett to disappear.
I didn't want the audience to say,
why does Gloria Pritchett think
that with that rubber nose,
she can, you know, trick us
into that she's a dramatic,
you know, killer actress, you know?
- It happens, you are.
- But I was worried the whole time.
I was like, are they gonna see
Gloria Pritchett in Griselda?
I mean -
- [Kelly] No.
- Did you see it?
- You don't see you at
all in this character.
It's like insane.
(laughs)
I just remember going,
wait, what happened?
What did they do?
I don't understand.
Even your voice is different.
- The way I walked, I had
to learn how to smoke,
I had to learn, I don't
know if I can say that here,
to do cocaine, but-
- Yeah.
- But not real cocaine, of course.
Fake cocaine, like, a thing.
But I was 50 years old
and I had never even
touched a cigarette, so I
had to learn how to hold it.
- Yeah.
(applause)
- That was stressing me, because you know,
people that have been
smoking their whole life,
they're like -
- It's so innate.
- It's an extension of their arm.
And I was at the beginning like:
- Well if you were doing this,
then you're used to smoking something.
(applause)
(laughter)
I'm just messing with you.
All right, let's take another break.
Griselda premieres tomorrow on Netflix.
Y'all have got to check it out.